eine sehr gewagte aber dennoch
interessante wahl
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
beim ein video schaut ihr euch jetzt
erstmal warten entschuldigt wird diese
hintergrundgeräusche es wird ungelogen
seitdem wir hier wohnen vor unsere
haustür gegen die gebaggert gebohrt oder
sonstwas um grad ist es wieder besonders
stimmen aber egal bevor wir mit dem
heutigen video anfangen ich habe es
gestern video schon gesagt heute wird
wieder was harmlos und heute echt nur
was cooles verlust war sie mal kurz was
könnte das sein erläutern die schon
mitbekommen haben zwei paris sind auch
dabei das coole allerdings ich habe noch
gar nicht gesagt welches partys ist also
es könnten ja welche seien von 2015 das
können auch welche seite von 2018
theoretisch die schon habt aber hab ich
nicht deswegen ich hoffe ihr seid immer
noch gespannt moment als wir haben hier
einen ganz neuen gysi der kam vor drei
wochen raus gray
ich kenne mich mit den namen immer noch
nicht so gut aus wie luc abalo gray kein
plan ist auf jeden fall ein original als
teil von der originalen an ihrer seite
ich würde mal sagen hat auf jeden fall
ein wert von 400 euro oder so und kann
natürlich von jungs und mädchen getragen
werden auf der gleichen schwierigen dem
anderen drin ist weiß ich nicht
könnte sein muss aber nicht sein das war
sicherlich was muss ich machen damit ich
den zugewinne ganz einfach wie immer die
verlosung ist für abonnenten die müssen
doch nach oben da lassen und einfach
zuviel kommentar schreiben wie ihr wollt
ich werde von allen kommentare
schreibern am 26 dezember kommt
voraussichtlich das video oder er vom
einreichen zimmer weiß nicht wo halt
alle gewinner aufgelistet werden und
dort welchen einen von allen kommentaren
ausbilden und der hat dann halt gewonnen
also wenn er zahlt 5 kommentare schreibt
sollte man öfter in den kommentaren
schon wieder weg was wir noch ganz
wichtig ist sicherlich fraglich
das ist doch bestimmt gar nicht meine
größte übrigens sorry dass hier so viel
war ja das stimmt dieses ist jetzt 43
nun mal ganz theoretisch gab mir zum
beispiel größe 39 das sind ließ sie
passt sich ziemlich einfach an der
schuhgröße 40 dh das würde auch dem wenn
jetzt zum beispiel größe 41 braucht dann
hätte ich theoretisch größe 41 auch noch
so müsste ich den halt umtauschen
geringen größe 1 40 ich bin also viel
glück wir fangen jetzt aber an mit dem
heutigen video auf dass wir bestimmt
alle sehr sehr doll gewartet habt und
zwar war alex wieder einkaufen heute
wird gekocht nicht gekocht aber
vergessen wir haben aber käse wir haben
gesagt wir haben ihre meldungen
wir haben ja basteln gerne passend zur
weihnachtszeit spekulatius wir haben
passend zu der länge
das kann ich nicht sagen wir haben hier
eine gurke und wir haben erdbeeren und
das allerwichtigste ist wir haben 750
gramm nutella ich habe euch letztens in
einem video mal gesagt ja ich hatte
schon immer noch kein video zu einem
teller zu machen einfach weil ich schon
immer eine tolle ärztin und ihr solltet
ihr in die kommentare schreiben was ich
denn damit machen soll und der kommentar
mit den meisten likes war ich soll
einfach mal alles möglich worauf ich
bock habt mit nutella probieren also war
ich noch einkaufen und heute werden wir
alles mögliche und wirklich alles
mögliche mit einem teller probieren was
aber ganz wichtig ist wir werden die
nutella erstmal ein bisschen schmelzen
damit das ganze viel daraus steht also
das mache jetzt erstmal wir sehen uns
gleich wird okay leute war es nicht
einfach genauso wie diese kripp stände
auf irgendwelchen weihnachtsmärkte oder
kirmes oder so
keine ahnung also leute passt auf so
leute also ich würde sagen wir fangen
sofort machen ich habe mir nach dem
teller dazu geholt
ich glaube es ist einfach erst mal
dieses spekulativ gewesen
dann werden wir einen keks jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt lasst euch dabei auf keinen
fall von euren eltern erwischen weil es
schon hart ungesund glaube ich nicht
dass es noch ärger gibt also da muss
jetzt will ich zu ihnen das war ein
bisschen sehr viel nutella ist auf jeden
fall jetzt nicht schlecht aber ist auch
nichts wo ich sage boah sind teller mit
mit hexen megageil aber es lag ich würde
sagen machen einfach mal mit den ärzten
weiter klar ehrt werden kennt man
eigentlich mit schokolade aber erst wenn
mit einem teller sich jetzt auch noch
nicht gegessen
also erstmal immer so also er hat weder
seien ja also das ist wirklich richtig
gut wenn die marburger auf süßigkeiten
holt euch einen teller macht sie so ein
bisschen flüssig und tod beim rhein ich
weiß gar nicht ob mein hund jetzt total
dreckig ist oder ob das noch geht einmal
geht noch wirklich richtig richtig
lecker so die meisten von euch fragen
sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
der will doch jetzt nicht ernsthaft käse
mit einem teller essen guckt euch das
ding ist käse mag ich echt richtig gerne
und so teller mag ich auch sehr gerne
und ich kenne auch sehr viele leute die
ersten zum beispiel morgens zum
frühstück marmelade mit käse käse mit
nutella habe ich jetzt leider nicht
gehört aber dann kannst du mal probieren
also leute wir machen das teil auf ein
baby salacca und betrunken den bdb in
die nutella
schaut euch das an wahnsinn guck mal
sieht aus wie ein mond so stimmgewalt
also etwa und spaß ich sag das jetzt
nicht weil ich es nur für das video
haben will das ist cool ist das schmeckt
jetzt wirklich nicht schlecht also es
schmeckt jetzt auch nicht was ist gut
aber es schmeckt kann er raus war seine
kettensäge ausmachen
danke also der nothelfer geschmack
übersieht leicht
ich habe da jetzt echt nix zu sagen gar
nicht mal schlecht so leute als nächstes
ist jetzt ein bisschen marshmallow mäßig
jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt also
hier könnte ich mir auch vorstellen das
ist gar nicht mal schlecht schmeckt und
ich muss ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
weil ich glaube das habe ich vielleicht
bauchschmerzen ja damit sie morgen ich
kann mir vorstellen richtigen maßen des
schreckens bestimmt noch besser aber es
ist schon ganz gut jetzt haben wir hier
in schuss was ich mir dabei gedacht habe
eigentlich gerade selber nicht aber
vielleicht ist ja diese mischung aus
salzig und süß die den geschmack auf ein
anderes level bringt es könnte sein dass
ich hier mit eine neue kreationen
drittel
ok also rein damit
schwierig jetzt gerade geht es da aber
ich glaube wenn man da von 1 34 stück am
stück ist ist es nicht mehr so lecker
also niemand leckerer käse denn der ist
besser so bin ich jetzt aber meine weiße
hoffnung stecke sind diese waffe hier
wir haben hier eine wunderschöne kleine
herz waffel und hier haben wir
wunderschönen teller und wir machen
jetzt mal folgendes leute schaut euch
das an so ein kleines stückchen von lets
go die waffen ist ein bisschen trocken
aber man muss sagen wie nutella holt das
wieder raus also ich glaube wenn man
richtig leckere waffeln hat dann
schmeckt es auch richtig gut ich muss
jetzt einen gang zurückschalten weil ich
merke schon dass es nicht gar nicht gut
für meinen brauche man alles
durcheinander ist das ja auch logisch
aber muss ja auch in die gesunde
ernährung denken das habe ich mir auch
bei diesem video gedacht er allerdings
das wird so ungesund du brauchst auch
ein bisschen vitaminen dabei ja und dann
habe ich jetzt zu dieser wurzel
gegriffen
eine sehr gewagte aber dennoch
interessante wahl an sich früher machte
ich nie guten aber mittlerweile kann man
das sogar essen also leute let's go das
mache ich eigentlich gerade sollte ich
vielleicht freuen
ich muss erstmal ein stück abschneiden
okay ich habe jetzt ein ganz schönes
stück hier jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
also es kann natürlich auch sein dass es
nur an mir liegt und ich halt irgendwie
alles mit mir leisten kann
aber das ist alles schon wieder gar
nicht mal so schlecht meine fans ja
sagen wir mal ob wir dann treiben oder
so natürlich waren die erdbahn hier am
meisten von der ich jetzt zumindest aber
viele andere sachen hier sind auch gut
vielleicht folgen dann spricht weil ja
heute so viel erst mal zu meinem teller
video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen könnte
meinen kommentar schreiben was man
eventuell noch damit kombinieren könnte
was sonst normalerweise keine macht ich
meine darum ging es ja heute auch
eigentlich ansonsten und auf jeden fall
an einem gewinnspiel teil
die echten gelder schuh ich hab noch mal
nachgeguckt balluff agri v ach ja sogar
jesu boost 350 schaut 2
dieses tool kann man ab sofort jetzt
auch gewinnen anders sehen wir uns
natürlich morgen wieder morgen 19 uhr
kommt ein cooles video haut rein